The tricky part is if I have an expression like m*x + b
I want to make sure that I parse that as if m and x are together and not x and b are together.
Another way to say that is I want to see any expression as if it were the sequence
of something plus something else plus something else.
These pluses can also be minus signs,
but anything with the time sign, I want to have that all be within the dot-dot-dot
rather than encompassing a plus sign in it.
What I want to do is write a grammar that defines the language of these expressions.
Grammar is a description. It's finite in length, and it should be easy to write.
A language is the set of all possible strings that that grammar describes.
I want to be able to say that in a concise language.
Maybe something like saying I'm going to define expressions,
and I want to define the expression as something that looks like this.
I need a name for the dot-dot-dots.
Let's call that a term.
An expression can be a term, a minus or a plus.
Let's use regular expression notation to describe a plus or minus.
Then more terms, but I can just say recursively that that's an expression.
That will give me any number of terms with plus and minuses in between them.
That's one possibility, but that's recursive, and I need a base case
so I can say it can also be the case that an expression can consist of a single term--
a + b is an expression, a + b + c is an expression, and also just a.
That's the rule for expression.
Then I would write the rule for term.
It would be similar.
It would take into account the multiply and divide,
and I would write the rest of the grammar in this format.
Notice here I've just sort of made up--I've used wishful thinking
to say I wish I had a notation like this to describe what the grammar is.